[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et on attend
vos points de vue notamment sur le
télétravail faut-il en faire plus c'est
ce que réclame à la ministre de l'emploi
et de l'insertion professionnelle
elisabeth bornes
alors êtes vous d'accord ou bien
trouvez-vous la ministre déconnecté
j'attends vos points de vue j'attends
également vos témoignages sur la
question est aussi celui de sophie de
menthon bonsoir sophie présidente
d'ethic entrepreneuse également et avec
vous avec nous ce soir
adrien le jeune adrien matou rescapés de
l'aco vide alors en fait il n'avait pas
la copine mais il était qu'à contacter
au moins on espère que ça va bien mieux
tout allait bien et tout va toujours
bien journaliste à marianne et auteur de
l'indispensable mélenchon la chute aux
éditions du rocher
l'autre débat ce soir sur lequel
d'ailleurs
jenson s'est exprimé c'est que faut-il
faire de la dette contractée à cause de
la crise de la queue vide l'annuler
l'échelonner la rembourser
éventuellement eh bien on en débat mais
d'abord si vous en avez ras l'bol comme
certains du télétravail
certains partis ne sont pas revenus
depuis mars dernier donc depuis près
d'un an
et bien ne comptez pas sur elisabeth
bornes pour vous soutenir dans vos
souhaits de retour pour la ministre du
travail et bien vivre le télétravail il
faut se remobiliser
on sait que c'est un très bon outil pour
lutter contre justement la propagation
du virus
on a des études qui nous montrent que
c'est entre 20 et 30 % de risque de
moins quand on est en télétravail
donc il faut se remobiliser c'est bien
ce que moi je suis en train de faire en
appelant effectivement en échangeant
avec des entreprises avec des drh
on a aussi remobiliser les services de
mon ministère notamment l'inspection du
travail qui intervient beaucoup en
entreprise pour aider palier pour
conseiller pour contrôler le cas échéant
pour sanctionner
sophie est ce que vous pouvez vous
donner votre point de vue après avoir
écouté les aubades bornes je dirais pas
que vous l'avez écouté religieusement
parce que c'était difficile vous
maîtrisez diaboliquement je l'écouté
mais bon c'est pas compliqué je crois
que je préférais martine aubry quand on
connaît mes opinions sur les 35 heures
je voyais ce que ça veut dire je veux
regarder adria mais à la limite martine
aubry avait dans une entreprise du la
relation etc
quand vous entendez ce soir ce soir ce
soir et coûter cher internaute sophie de
menthon viennent nous dire que martine
aubry avait le sens de l'entreprise
ne vous inquiétez pas je ne pense pas
que ce film anton est viré sa cuti
je vous redonne la parole je disais que
malheureusement elisabeth bonne est en
permanence en hostilité avec les
entreprises
je veux dire on a du mal c'est difficile
on a contre nous une ministre comment
est-ce qu'elle ose en ce moment dire
ouais j'suis vraiment bon âge est
mobilisée l'inspection du travail et
quand elle dit que l'inspection est là
pour conseiller les chefs d'entreprise
je vous conseille d'avoir une relation
amicale et détendue à l'inspecteur du
travail qui vient chez vous pour
contrôler ceux qui ont déjà vécu ça je
pense le diront peut-être à l'antenne
donc allons même moment je reçois une
incitation légitime de la part d' en
particulier de valérie carmack députés
en marche et qui nous dit les jeunes
n'en peuvent plus
recruter des stagiaires je vous en
supplie seront faits immédiatement
éthiques on est dehors de ce que dit le
borgne
elisabeth bande pendant le chemin
confrérie vidal elisabeth barbe à ce
qu'a dit les aveux de bornes également
c'est également ce matelas et bien c'est
pas compliqué j'ai deux stagiaires je
leur ai dit bon je recruterai bien mais
vous mettrez pas à pied dans
l'entreprise
or on a besoin de les recruter pour
qu'il connaisse entreprises pour qu'ils
aient un peu de chaleur humaine pour
qu'ils trouvent un sens à leur vie
ils sont derrière nous les a montrés
sans arrêt tout seuls certains dans des
chambres derrière leurs ordis toute la
journée
comment est-ce qu'on voit que je vais
recruter deux stagiaires pour pas les
voir cette petite à vraisemblable donc
on a des contradictions de ce type
quant au télétravail c'est très
difficilement supportable
psychologiquement pour certains salariés
pour d'autres il apprécie
d'autres ont leur a tellement fait peur
ils sont terrifiés quand ils viennent
dans l'entreprise on est obligé de se
masquer du mat à distance d'ouvrir les
fenêtres fin on fait tout bien
parce que les entreprises ont été
parfaites sur ce genre de bon je crois
que j'ai vu que vous n'êtes pas prête à
en faire un petit peu plus comme
l'appelle demandé 10 abc qu'on va faire
plus
alors c'est quoi en faire plus justement
peut-être certains chiffres qui sont
données à l'appui qui ont été retrouvés
par albin alba bloc que je félicite
près d'un an après le début de la crise
qu vide
le nombre de télétravailleurs a atteint
effectivement 41 % des salariés mais au
moins de novembre dernier selon donc
malakoff humanis 31 % des salariés
seulement sont en télétravail en
décembre 2020 et alors qu'ils étaient
30% en novembre 2010 9 adria votre point
de vue sur la sur la question est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec sophie ou bien
ou bien vous tout penser qu'il faut
comme le dit offre et de bornes en faire
plus en matière de télétravail alors bad
et j'attends vos témoignages
la première chose qu'il faut rappeler
c'est que c'est un débat qui concerne
une minorité salariés mais que parce que
tout simplement parce que beaucoup de
professions ne peuvent pas télétravail
et ça me paraît important de le rappeler
alors certes il n'ya pas que les cadres
qui télétravaillent mais là vous êtes en
train de dire que c'était pas la peine
qu'on fasse non pas du tout pas du tout
mais je pense que c'est important de le
rappeler parce que à chaque fois qu'on
lance le débat sur la taille d'un
journaliste ce n'est pas du tout pour
vous mettre en difficulté c'était juste
pour rappeler que quand on est ouvrier
canton infirmières quand on dit ça quand
on est coiffeur etc
quand on est pour être maître de
demander à sophie lemaître silencieux
quand on les policiers quand on est
militaire voilà on peut pas de
télétravail est donc
les cadres même s'il n'ya pas que les
cadres qui télétravaillent ses 20% de la
population alors ceci dit la remarque
que je ferai ensuite c'est que la france
se caractérise par rapport à d'autres
pays par son absence totale de
contraintes sur le télétravail pour
l'instant c'est à dire que les
entreprises n'ont pas n'ont aucune
obligation de de faire du télétravail
les entreprises peuvent même contraindre
un salarié qui ne voudrait pas à
télétravailler ou à venir ou et lé
travail et donc ceci dit enfin moi
j'avais vu les rues on est descendu mais
déçu au stade où on a le droit de
reprendre un salarié au télétravail qui
demandent à revenir parce qu'il n'est
pas bien à condition que ce soit un jour
par semaine ça serait la dernière
nouvelle
oui mais en tout cas le l'arrangement
initiale qui avait été décidée c'était
plutôt conformes au soin des entreprises
qui a été une grande souplesse sur ces
questions là donc moi je constate qu'il
ya quand même beaucoup moins de
télétravail qu'au premier confinement je
crois qu'il ya un chiffre qui est
circulaire que on est on est on a
atteint 41 % des salariés donc lors du
premier confinement et 31
31 % en décembre 2001 g donc à l'issue
du deuxième confirmé moi je vais vous
dire pourquoi je trouvais ça pas
légitime d'en faire plus mais il faut
préciser qu est ce que veut dire en
faire plus peut-être qu'on précise
adrien et sophie deux points quand même
c'est que le nombre de jours télétravail
et continue donc lui d'être d'être élevé
donc de toute façon lui il a augmenté
on est à 3,6 jours par semaine en
moyenne
alors qu'on était à un petit peu plus
d'un jour un jour 26 à fin 2017 parmi
les gens qui étaient les travailler
voilà absolument larini absolue ce kit
arrêté le travail dans l'entreprise
oui mais ce qui t'est de travail
télétravail beaucoup plus frais dire
qu'avant un genre prend quand on était
en télétravail si on on était considéré
en télétravail quand c'était un jour par
semaine maintenant quand on est en
télétravail c'est plus de 3 jours par
semaine et surtout 45 % des salariés en
télétravail pour quasiment la moitié le
fond à 100% c'est ça qui ne quittent
jamais leur de ne jamais et donc on a
des témoignages de gens qui par exemple
depuis le 2ème confinement ne sont pas
encore à ce mot en ce jour revenu en
présentiel dans l'ordre la reprise alors
elle ne tient pas compte de tout ce que
toutes les répercussions que ça peut
avoir sur une entreprise les salariés
sont formidables en télétravail
franchement la plupart du temps il faut
nos noms mais je veux c'est vrai c'est
de bosser etc mais commence maintenant à
y avoir les syndicats qui s'en mêle donc
alors il y avait une sombre histoire de
ticket restaurant
est ce que en télétravail vous devez
avoir un ticket restaurant surtout qu'il
n'y a pas de restaurants ouverts et que
en principe vous êtes supposé quand même
vous nourrir parce que vous êtes chez
vous et que c'est juste le ticket
restaurant c'est parce qu'il ya pas de
structure de l'entreprise
alors là c'est tu veux ça va commencer
ensuite ça coûte aux salariés il faut le
savoir je crois j'ai plus chips très bas
mais en chiffres 17% 2
on va on va essayer de le retrouver
effectivement alors choix que ses
confrères du parisien sont facturés à
une affaire très intéressante qui a
montré que je peux vous donner
d'ailleurs le témoignage d'année
mes confrères dans mes homologues qui
m'a expliqué que sa facture de chauffage
et d'électricité sur toute électrique a
littéralement explosé depuis mars
d'armes donc ça va est évidemment l
entreprise de le payer
vous pensez bien quand même qu'on va y
venir donc c'est en plus il faut quand
même savoir il n'y a pas de chine ne
serait pas normal
alors c'est une vraie question la
question et que d'abord c'est pas
l'entreprise qui choisit les mettrent en
télétravail ensuite de ça il faut quand
même savoir quand lé travail même s'ils
font des efforts
l'entreprise perd de sa substance de son
dynamisme et de son activité commerciale
moi je vois très bien quand on est une
fois par semaine réunit à éthique et
sert à ça fuse
est ce que tu as fait ça ah non j'ai pas
eu le temps tu as fais le toi c on passe
notre vie à essayer de savoir si c'est
untel ou unetelle qui qui fait le
travail confié chez eux
donc ça veut dire que l'entreprise y
perd sur tous les plans elle a envie
elle aime ses salariés figurez-vous l
envie de les voir elle a besoin d'eux on
oublie les patrons et patrons ont besoin
de leurs salariés plus que les salariés
ont besoin de leur patron sinon nature
pas bah oui non oui et on n'arrive pas à
gérer nos bois 200e donc cesser perdons
c'est un calcul qui est perdant ça c'est
un débat les salariés le rapport
salarial est trop mais il y avait un
aspect sanitaire qu'il faut rappeler
c'est à dire que oui moi je quand même
je constate quand même que les
contraintes qui pèsent sur les bars les
restaurants le sport le monde de la
culture
je veux dire tous les scénarii fermé moi
je comprenne vraiment pourquoi pas non
plus de l'autre côté sur le télétravail
il ya très peu de contraintes pour
l'instant c'est un peu à la carte quand
on fait ce qu'on veut
finalement donc pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas faire peser des contraintes un petit
peu plus élevée sur les entreprises
notamment pour les salariés qui ne
souhaitent pas aller travailler parce
qu'ils ont peur de contracter le coc
vidéos etc
ceci dit par exemple vous avez
aujourd'hui on les pratique vous avez
des entreprises respectivement on prend
peut-être l'exemple de nos entreprises
cit était des salles pour des questions
sanitaires ne veulent pas ne veulent pas
c'est à dire que en fonction des
recommandations sanitaires on est soit
le télétravail devient
règle soit le retour en présidentielle
devient la règle devient la règle c'est
faux pas de règle par exemple j'ai nommé
il ya salariés qui habitent exactement à
250 mètres à pied du bureau il ya celles
qui prend le métro pendant une heure
c'est les mâles c'est différent je
trouve pas moi j'ai offert des vélos
parce que il n'y a pas de raison après
tout paris c'est une telle taxe
catastrophe pour circuler en voiture que
autant joué le jeu et prendre des vélos
c'est pas la même chose
personne ne parle jamais des transports
en commun mais ça c'est sûr par exemple
je répète l'exemple mais on peut pas
aller au cinéma
par contre le sait le métro à 18h et
bondés rappellera que elisabeth delorme
a été patron de la ratp
bien sûr mais ceci dit la rue d'accord
on a supprimé les rames comme ça les
gens sont plus serrés là où je suis
d'accord avec sophie c'est qu'il ya un
aspect socialisation de l'entreprise qui
est extrêmement important et ça peut
être extrêmement pesant pour un salarié
de decroix ces personnes d'être toute la
journée tout seul et c'est alors après
il ya un autre aspect qui peut-être mois
à sophie mais le danger à terme du
télétravail c'est quand même le fait que
par exemple pour faire un syndicat pour
s'organiser entre salariés pour défendre
ses intérêts bah oui c'est pas facile en
télétravail si chacun est tout seul chez
soi c'est dommage c'est donc là peut
être que vous serez plus favorable se
fie au télétravail mais je pense que ça
peut aussi être un danger à l'avenir si
on est tous isolés tout seul dans notre
coin à télétravailler ça peut aussi être
mais sa tion des cas de figure c'est
extrêmement variées vous avez des
entreprises où les gens veulent
télétravail et on les oblige à venir
d'autres ou celle inverse il n'y a pas
vraiment de règle une autre aberration
si vous permet oui puis on va donner
justement la parole et senteurs de récré
moyen plus facile parce qu'elle disait
bête bordeaux son immense bonté vient de
faire passer à décrire qui permet de
prendre ses repas au bureau alors
premièrement on n'a pas le droit d'aller
au bureau mais on peut y prendre ses
repas et ensuite de ça est ce qu'elle
s'imagine que tous les salariés ou 80%
des salariés dans les bureaux n'ont pas
été chercher leur salade au coin de la
rue et non pas pris aux bureaux salles
de réunion avec des collègues je veux
dire c'est une ignorance complète de ce
qui se passe et on savait même pas que
c'était interdit figurez vous nathan 700
sont dits est d'accord il ne faut pas de
règle enfin une parole sage de madame de
anton mon métier ne me permet pas de
faire du télétravail dire anthony sur
youtube c'est ce que nous dit vous
disiez justement tout à l'heure il ya un
certain nombre de professions qui ne
peuvent pas faire du télétravail tout ce
qui est le bâtiment la restauration
outre la télé travaille à 100% c'est
trop dur pour les personnes seules elles
se retrouvent piégées à la maison
témoigne frédéric beaucoup de gens on en
marre du twr du télétravail nous dit
marianne mais c'est le prénom le
télétravail n'est pas possible partout
effectivement le dit bleu et nicole 06
nous dit bornes c'est elle qui dit aux
stations de ski d'embaucher des
interviews pour les mettre en chômage
partiel
ensuite c'est pas vous comme 0,6
sophie zoya le dise l'être humain a
besoin de se socialiser voir ses
collègues de travail est essentiel les
salariés ne devrait-il pas pouvoir
choisir vous dit le prince
qu'est ce que vous en pensez d'abord et
choisissent c'est le cas franchement
vous êtes dans une entreprise
aujourd'hui tel climat il y en a une lui
dire non mais moi je viens pas
d'ailleurs c'est pas le ministre a dit
pardon la loi pas moi j'ai lu ce matin
un article d'une goutte d'une part une
collecte et loyal qui racontait beaucoup
de cas de salariés qu'ils ont forcé de
venir travailler par leur patron au
boulot oui bien sûr mais d'ailleurs ça
m'est arrivé de les forcer
je vous laisse pas du coup ci parce que
vous le faites une fois et puis après
tout tout l'entreprise se met à décider
alors on fait un roulement
on comprend que l aile à une heure de
yaël à une heure de transport il est
évident qu'on va pas la force et donc si
vous voulez ce qui se passe c'est que
les salariés vous pouvez pas lutter
d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup de patrons de
il ya un climat parfois tendu parce que
vous en avez qui sont morts de peur
qu'ils veulent absolument pas aller dans
l'entreprise donc on n'ose pas leur dire
il ya le risque de l'inspection du
travail puisqu'il ya des menaces quand
même clair et net
donc oui en l'absence de loire en
l'absence de loi parce que là ce que
vous dites c'est celle qui écologique
mais c'est un peu laissée au bon vouloir
du patron oui et non elle a quand même
dit qu'il y avait une règle en ce moment
en période pandémique
il y avait tout le monde était en
télétravail sauf si on pouvait le faire
mais c'est pas oubliée et l'inspection
du travail à faire quoi alors vinci a
pas de l'ol pourra rien faire mais
moi justement je suis déçu je suis de
ceux qui sont plus tôt pour qu'il ait
une règle parce que je pense que la loi
protège et pour le coup s'il ya une
règle qui est claire je trouve ça
beaucoup plus sain que de faire au cas
par cas comme ça où ça dépend des
entreprises faut faire confiance ce soir
de prime aux salariés
moi je pense qu'en cas de en cas de
conflit entre l'entreprise et le salarié
c'est bien qu'il ya une règle pour
trancher parce que sinon ça va être
entreprise qui va ternir ce moment sol
et une solidarité vous savez dans les
boîtes personne n'a envie d'abord de de
voir quelqu'un tomber malade personne
n'a envie de d'avoir quelqu'un qui prend
vraiment des crises dans les 3 6 ans
comme eyes habillage c'est une
solidarité dans les boîtes ça me posera
aucun problème qui est une règle puisque
les règles sont déjà respectée non parce
que les règles qu'est ce qu'elle va
faire
ce sera une règle même voiture pour tout
le monde tout le monde aura droit à deux
jours de télétravail par semaine elle a
déjà dit que après cette pandémie
lloret c'était déjà un peu ça c'était
déjà un peu dans les tuyaux il y aurait
un jour obligatoire six salariés elle
voulait de télétravail c'est une
organisation du travail elle se met à la
place des patrons pourquoi est justement
pourquoi ces types d'entreprises qui a
besoin de leurs salariés seraient pas
soumises à cette règle alors que tous
les genres l'ailé les coiffeurs les
commerçants les infirmières les enfin
tout tout tout ce qu'ils ont dans le
travail nécessite de sortir mais moi je
trouve ça un peu curieux de dire tout se
passe bien mais par contre aucune règle
parce que attention si tout se passe
bien pourquoi c'est pourquoi ça posera
un problème qui ne règlent tout se passe
bien mais c'est très difficile et la
règle pas de vrai qu'il va faire que ça
se passera plus mal j'ai un ami qui a
arrêté de faire du télétravail corps son
réseau en fait était trop mauvais
témoigne encore nicole 0,6 nathan 770
nous estime que les gens n'aiment pas
télétravail et un jour par semaine ça le
rend service au delà on les rend
dépressif et santoni ce jeu
vous donne la parole à une suite adrien
puis on va passer au deuxième sujet mais
par contre je suis pas sûr que vous ayez
raison tous les cas la question qu'on a
posés sur twitter ses fautes il
renforcer encore davantage de recours au
télétravail
et la réponse est oui à 63% et non à 37%
je salue le retour d'un internaute qu'on
n'avait pas vu depuis très longtemps qui
est le droitiste et qui nous demande
excusez moi mais madame de menton dirige
quelle entreprise séquence pub non
rémunéré alesis alors ma propre
entreprise qui s dé me qui n'est pas
concerné par ça et surtout mon syndicat
où il ya quand même cette personne qui
s'appelle éthique qui est un mouvement
patronal qui travaille exactement comme
une entreprise et donc voilà des mois
avant j'avais pour renseigner notre
auditeur j'avais un centre d'appels que
j'ai vendu avec 1800 salariés ne vendra
pas combien ça vous dirait comme le
télétravail fonctionne pas terrible oh
ben alors et vous savez pourquoi
non parce que c'était un centre d'appels
donc c'était des entreprises qui ont
énormément de salariés et avoir des
salariés en france et diminue
considérablement le prix de vente de
l'entreprise
alors après c'est peut-être vous faites
tête du bluff en fait vous l'avez
peut-être très bien vendu mais vous
croire que vous le valez rien à voir du
saas ça c'est le business aussi le
télétravail fonctionne pour une partie
de la population et pour les autres mais
justement c'est ce que on a vu c'est
qu'il ya eu toute une partie des
professions qui ne peuvent pas avoir
recours au télétravail
le salarié qui a des frères en plus chez
lui a quand même des frais au moins au
niveau transport et repas nous disent
itx oui mais il a des frais
supplémentaires en matière d'électricité
c'est ce que révèle en tous les cas un
certain nombre d'articles qui ont été
faits sur la question et que vous pouvez
retrouver également sur le site du
figaro alors il leur en a marre du
télétravail je m'arrange pour aller au
boulot deux fois par semaine et si tu
nous dis perso je suis indépendant je
bosse à 100% télétravail et ça me plaît
surtout talent et travail est
incompatible avec des enfants en
vacances ou confinées témoigne chardon
bleu et nat 1 770 encore on pourrait
réduire les charges sociales urssaf des
salaires des salariés passés en
télétravail point d'interrogation
puisque ont réduit leur risque d'être
malade et l'on nous dit je dois sortir
de chez moi
on va faire des cotisations par ailleurs
comment les charges ça s'appelle des
cotisations oui c'est une cotisation
n'est effectivement c'est peut-être une
question qui peuvent ce qui peut se
poser sur sur des réductions de charges
non non bon donc vous nous direz
pourquoi on voit très clair vous ne
direz pourquoi dans un autre dans un
autre débat parce qu'on va là on a pris
un petit peu de temps et il ya une autre
question je voudrais voir avec vous
c'est sur cette question de la dette aux
états unis
1900 milliards de dollars sont mobilisés
pour relancer l'économie après la
corrida en france l'état lui est plus
vaste il a effectivement déboursé 40 4
milliards d'euros au 31 décembre en
particulier donc pour le quoi qu'il en
coûte et notamment sur les questions qui
sont liées à l'activité partielle mais
ces dépenses s'ajoute aux dettes
colossales plan déjà été contractée
alors alors faut-il les rembourser que
fait-on de tout cet argent qui a été
dépensé et bien je vous propose
d'écouter deux réponses qui répondent
qu'ils correspondent à deux visions
d'abord celle de l'économiste thomas
piketty
en gros tout le monde est d'accord sur
le fait qu'on va surtout ne jamais la
rembourser après certains à partir de là
certains disent bon de toute façon comme
on ne va pas la rembourser que c'est un
taux d'intérêt zéro ça sert à rien de
l'annuler on pourrait la laisser comme
ça sur le bilan de la bce pendant 50 ans
c'est vrai que nous la position qu'on
défend est un peu différente de lire
écouter puisque si on est d'accord sur
le fait qu'on va jamais la rembourser il
faudra mieux officialisé la situation
alors ça va pas tout régler sire que de
toute façon moi je veux vraiment
insister sur le sur le fait que à la fin
des fins il faudra un prélèvement sur
les plus grandes fortunes privées pour
vraiment réduire l'endettement au cervin
votre point de vue sophie je vous
propose d'écouter le point de vue de
quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien c'est
geoffroy route des yeux
le patron du medef pour moi je fais pas
partie de ceux qui disent la dette ça se
rembourse pas la dette ça peut s'étaler
ça peut se mettre dans plusieurs
compartiments en fonction de la nature
et de l'origine encore une dette
qu'ovide mais un moment la crédibilité
de la france et de l'europe
c'est de rembourser sa dette on a
toujours rembourser nos dettes depuis
200 ans simplement il ya deux manières
de rembourser la dette
on a une qui est d'augmenter les impôts
et on sait que ça fonctionne pas à vous
une passe a ralenti l'économie et l'eau
que c'est faire la croissance est élancé
de la croissance sophie votre point de
vue je pose qu'il a parfaitement raison
alors deux jours nommé en france et
qu'une bonne analyse
il est censé c'est un vrai chef
d'entreprise c'est vrai que on a
l'habitude de rembourser nos dettes
alors il ya cela dit c'est un sujet très
compliqué il ya 1500 économistes dans le
monde qui disent que il faudrait annuler
cette dette de l'économie suisse à 100
150 économistes dans le monde qui dit
faudrait combler complètement l'annuler
d'un autre commis dans sa vie alors il
ya deux dettes ya la dette en général la
dette de l'état et puis à la dette que
vite c'est encore autre chose mais il ya
également ceux qui disent que on a des
capacités d'emprunt à taux zéro et que
c'est quand même oui négatif
et ça c'est une telle la citation à
entreprendre et dès que ça va aller un
peu mieux si ça reste comme ça on a une
croissance qui risque de faire
rembourser la dette
complètement ensuite il faut se rappeler
que ces dettes on est en train de la
rembourser on rembourse simplement les
empreintes de la dette en ce moment mais
nous en parlerons de l'oxi les emprunts
ont la bosse actuellement la france
rembourse les empreintes de la dette
d'ailleurs rien que ça c'est quelque
chose de difficile il faut expliquer ce
qu'est ce que c'est que ce que sont les
emprunts
quand on emprunte de l'argent pour une
dette baiia tôt comme vous lorsque vous
allez prendre un crédit
votre crédit il était un certain taux
nous on n'a pas du tout les moyens de
rembourser note date donc hors embauches
juste les le taux d'accord et alors il
ya ça qui joue aussi en suite de ça les
français sur 51 % à penser que on n'y
croit pas du tout qui ait pas d'impôt
d'ailleurs il l'a dit différemment tout
à l'heure piketty en disant que non il
fallait évidemment taxer les grandes
fortunes
ça c'est une solution miracle formidable
bien bien pour paix les rythmes rock et
plus du tout de riches et donc il y aura
moins de pauvres ça c'est vraiment
l'erreur de base fondamentale en créer
c'est bien donc
en revanche c'est très difficile je suis
pour le remboursement de la dette
d'ailleurs la réalité aussi la
difficulté je finis par là c'est que si
vous voulez si vous remboursez pas
vedette on vous prêtent plus d'argent
parce que vous n'êtes plus crédible
mais si on est tous dans le même panier
ça pose moins de problèmes si toute
l'europe est endetté de la même façon si
le monde entier est endetté bon bah on
peut voir venir à ce moment là on
fabrique de la fausse monnaie et banque
centrale et puis on continue comme ça
alors adrien votre point de vue c'est
pas parce que notamment ce qui est dit
sophie
moi j'ai une question quand même
subsidiaire à l'opposé ce que j'épouse
république à jeu souverainiste interm ça
fait parti des verts je moi je
quand je regarde c'est que la dette
surtout en france quand même la gauche
libérale qui a été la droite par la
suite qu'ils ont été quand même ajouté à
ça sera vrai que c'est michel sapin
notamment en contractant sur les marchés
internationaux et autres points de vue
alors je vais essayer d'être clair dans
un débat technique mais très intéressant
mais les politiques éminemment politique
première chose il ya une dichotomie
fondamentale qui est que la dette est
une obsession médiatique et il ya un
consensus absolu des économistes pour
dire que ça n'a absolument rien de grave
le niveau de la dette qui alors on joue
à se faire peur en faisant des chiffres
2 milliards ou de pourcentage de pib etc
mais les taux d'intérêt n'ont pas
remonté depuis 12 ans ils sont
extrêmement faibles et la soutenabilité
de la dette c'est-à-dire la capacité de
la france mais aussi d'autres pays à
payer les intérêts de la dette chaque
année est absolument il ya aucun danger
ensuite j'ai envie d'ajouter que
l'expression rembourser la dette n'a
absolument aucun sens puisque l'état ne
va jamais rembourser la dette
on ne sera jamais à 0 % de la dette un
état ne fonctionne pas quand un ménage
c'est pas un état n'achète pas un frigo
et le remboursement de 20 ans c'est à
dire qu'un détail toujours endettés mais
il continue toujours de rembourser ses
créanciers ensuite de quoi on parle on
parle pas de la dette française en
général vous l'avez souligné vincent on
parle de la dette qu vide mais notamment
de la dette que là que la france et
d'autres états européens ont contracté
auprès de la bce
c'est à dire que c'est là-bas que
central europe c'est pas des
investisseurs qu'on a qu'on a vendu des
obligations d'état c'est la banque
centrale européenne qui gère l'euro qui
nous a acheté les obligations d'état
donc effectivement trouve l'argent se
demandent les gens bas parce que c'est
une banque centrale donc c'est pas de la
fausse monnaie c'est la création
monétaire
mais mais mais on va y revenir autant
dire que en quelque sorte on s'est prêté
de l'argent à nous mêmes c'est ce que
disent les économistes qui veulent
annuler la dette alors ceci dit moi je
ne suis pas pour l'annuler pourquoi mais
pas pour les mêmes raisons que geoffroy
roux de bézieux évidemment ce fut en
fait ce qui me pose problème
c'est que ces gens-là donc ces
économistes y plaident pour l'annulation
de la dette
j'ai plus de sympathie pour eux que pour
ceux qui disent oui il faut couper
toutes les dépenses publiques
il faut absolument ne faire aucun impôt
sur les plus riches il va falloir du
sang et des larmes pour pour rembourser
la dette
il m'inspire plus de sympathie mais leur
logique et une logique qui ne respectent
pas la souveraineté des peuples
pourquoi parce que au niveau européen ce
qu'on fait ce que fait la bce
c'est aujourd'hui grosso modo d'une île
du néolibéralisme et eux ce qu'ils
voudraient c'est que la bce joue un rôle
au niveau européen qui sont un rôle
social en disant voilà on annule la
dette ou fait de la création monétaire
ont fait de la planche à billets au
niveau européen
et peu importe ce que pensent les autres
états c'est pour leur bien et en fait ça
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
construction européenne on fait une
politique qui va dans le kiki et qu'on
peut qu'on y est conforme aux intérêts
des allemands et des pays bas malgré les
desiderata du peuple français et eux ce
qu'ils proposent c'est de faire une
politique européenne qui serait
contraire aux volontés des peuples je
sais pas néerlandais allemands ou
nordiques mais parce que c'est pour leur
bien c'est une logique qui ne me va pas
parce qu'elle ne respecte pas sur la
volonté démocratique des silhouettes et
des peuples
donc moi qu'est ce que je voudrais faire
j'ai fini juste rapidement sur sa ouais
je pense qu'en fait c'est tout
simplement le moment idéal pour que les
états investissent en masse mais au
niveau national c'est à dire que les
taux d'intérêt sont extrêmement faible
voire négative une politique de grands
travaux
exactement une politique de grands
travaux au niveau écologique à mon avis
et beaucoup de guerre mais pourquoi pas
mais avant je ne le connais pas à tête
de l'état mais je pense que c'est le
moment idéal pour que l'état français
investissent de manière massive hockey
et que à court terme ça ne va peut être
creuser l'endettement à court terme mais
ça va le résorber à long terme parce
qu'il ya un effet multiplicateur qui
sera bénéfique
vous parliez tout à l'heure la
croissance et geoffroy roux de bézieux
parler de la croissance françois barois
sophie ancien ministre de l'économie qui
n'est pas un gauchiste radical peu plus
kenya cévennes qui est eurodéputé membre
de la commission économique de l'onu
européen ou que le secrétaire général dr
aurélien pradié réclame dans le figaro
un allongement du remboursement de la
dette dans le figaro sur tout ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ils doutent
carrément de l'idée que la seule
croissance suffire à rembourser la
montagne de dette 120% cette année 100 %
dernier je sais que je donne des jeux
fait hérisser le poil rien en parlant de
ces chiffres colossaux
j'en sais rien je ne sais pas et
personne ici ne sait ce qui va se passer
si le vaccin marche que tout d'un coup
nous libère que dans huit mois
c'est l'explosion c'est le bonheur on
recommence à bosser on peut avoir une
croissance extraordinaire ça peut aussi
être un virus qui va durer quatre cinq
ans donc ça ça dépend considérablement
de ça je suis incapable de vous dire
s'il faut je partage assez ce que vous
avez dit sauf sur les grands travaux
parce que les gros travaux menés par
l'état si complètement artificiel je
crois pardonnez moi mais je crois
fondamentalement à l'entreprise privée
qui voient ça vous a pas échappé quitte
à ce que l'état fasse des commandes ou
de vous poser des des cahiers des
charges mais là c'est nous qui avons
qu'il faut sauver le pays de cette crise
à tous les points de vue sur les plans
sanitaire sur le plan économique et
c'est donc la politique gros travaux
engagés par l'état non sur ce plan là
peut-être cam adrien sans prendre parti
dans le débat mais on a quand même
constaté depuis le premier confinement
et à l'occasion du 2ème confinement
également la formidable inventivité et
mobilisation quand même des français des
entreprises françaises est ce que il
n'ya pas quand même un levier justement
de libération de l'activité par rapport
à ça oui mais en fait c'est mc c'est un
autre sujet même que la nba avec lui sur
la dette en fait mais il en fait il
s'agit pas de dire qu'il faut monter
l'impôt sur les sociétés à 30% et c est
en fait les grands travaux ça peut se
faire en collaboration avec des
entreprises privées
en fait l'idée pas forcément non mais
c'est un autre sujet mais on sait pas
pourquoi mais l'idée centrale maps
bontin le sujet mais je pense qu'il ya
un certain nombre de problèmes qui sont
qui ont été créés par un ace qu'on a
fait et y consacrer et c'est une société
de d'éthique qui crée une plateforme la
république des entrepreneurs en gros
c'est une plateforme où vous avez un
problème l'état un problème ou dans
l'intérêt général et enfin si une boîte
privée qui propose des solutions et ça
jamais l'état ne fait appel aux
solutions fait savoir l'entreprise alors
que le début il n'y a pas de gêne à gaz
on va faire pour
c'est dit sophie leta fait appel à un
cabinet privé pour gérer la médecine
c'est un autre important alors sur la
dette ça que c'est un choix pour
l'important la manière de rembourser la
dette est un choix politique
il ya plusieurs options on peut
effectivement choisir de tailler dans
les dépenses publiques et dans ce cas là
en fait il faut choisir qui on sacrifie
l'histoire est fier parce que pour
rembourser la dette il ya forcément des
gagnants et des perdants
je peux juste vous dire que l'angleterre
par exemple l'angleterre après les
guerres napoléoniennes à sabrer dans les
dépenses publiques des résultats
absolument désastreux chez les
catégories pauvres
après la seconde guerre mondiale on se
fait marcher la planche à billets la
fosse matière comme dirait comme dirait
sophie et là c'est l'euthanasie des
rentiers et c'est un problème pour les
rentiers donc c'est un choix politique
la manière dont on va près de la dame
qui à 130 milliards d'euros d'épargné
oui actuellement et que précisément ce
que disent ce que ce que disent ces
trois ces trois responsables dlr c'est
que il ya une crainte chez ses chais ces
épargnants est il justement à une peur
d'eux et un manque de confiance
vis-à-vis des politiques de l'état
c'est l'inflation est élevée je reprends
les commentaires des internautes quand
la bce aimé de la dette nous disent ici
tch on emprunte à personne c'est de
l'émission de dette
depuis les accords de la jamaïque de
1976 dit un syndicaliste qui est
internautes du figaro la monnaie n'a
plus de contrepartie la ddt et analyse
par le bce peut donc être supprimées
sans problème un jeu d'écritures nicole
0,6 mais depuis lors l'étalon or
nichols absolument nicole 06 nous dit
elle ne pourra jamais être remboursés
quelles sont les conséquences en cas
d'annulation de cette date nous dit
général et bien à l'instant général
adrien vient vous répondre soit on
sacrifie les pauvres seront sacrifiés
entier sait c'est une un dilemme
justement qui rend la question politique
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a posée parce que
c'est une question qui remet le tragique
au centre de la décision cette dette ne
sera pas annulée on aura des impôts et
des taxes pour la rembourser c'est
l'autre aspect est effectivement
difficile de cette décision à prendre
quand la bce aimé de la dette
donc ça c'est ce que me disait si tu che
taxer les grandes fortunes on sait
comment ça finit
les très riches en vain et ce sont les
autres qui payent je pense que sophie
sera d'accord avec cette analyse
la bce n'est mais pas de dette elle n'en
a pas besoin elle pêche et ce qu'elle
veut comme elle veut me dit un
syndicaliste alors non les seuls on est
traités européens en principal est pas
censé racheter la dette des états le le
déficit public structurel lui-même est
inacceptable il s'agit d' impôt déguisé
nous dit nathan 770 les citoyens
n'auront n'ont pas eu leur mot à dire
sur la gestion du coc vide ils ne sont
donc pas responsable de cette dette nous
dit lionel on aimerait vous croire je
suis favorable à l'abolition de la
monnaie unique nous dit romain sur
twitter à la restauration de la banque
de france
ce que c'est votre avis d'ailleurs
adrien cela oui enfin je sais pas si
refait en un claquement de doigts mais
oui à moyen terme si un état peut être
une une démocratie en réalité ils
doivent comprendre les bases de la
création monétaire sont à revoir nous
dit encore un syndicaliste de toute
façon la croissance il ne faut plus
compter dessus nous disent itx
alors justement sophie et plus
est moins pessimiste que vous il attend
cette soixante dix lui a choisi les
états doivent dépenser moins est ce vrai
et c'est le le point de vue également de
kriss kross il est temps de tailler dans
l'art des dépenses publiques
oui et à des algues répudie pourquoi ne
pas ponctionner un pourcentage sur tous
les produits des parts détenues pour la
seule date qu vide parce que ce serait
l'euthanasie des rentiers nous 10 avril
à tous et du vol ou 10 restants sophie
gauche place des solutions que le
taillage massives dans les dépenses
publiques
on m'a fortement c'est vous qui êtes un
adepte de la justice sociale est ce que
vous trouvez normal dans ce cas là dans
les textes des épargnants qui pour
certains ont su et toute leur vie et
qu'ils ont et qu'ils ont mis de côté cet
argent lundi je me suis pas pour une
taxe sur les épargnants je sais que
c'est une vraie crainte aujourd'hui moi
je suis pour une police et pour une
politique qui conduirait à de
l'inflation et qui en fait un titre et
ses épargnes les épargnants à investir
le problème d'entreprise
oui oui veulent le problème c'est que la
dette ne sert qu'à des dépenses de
fonctionnement jamais d'investissement
ça c'est une autre question
c'est tout le débat également qu'il ya
autour de la dette parce qu'il ya
certains disent que la dette c'est comme
le cholestérol ya une bonne des noces
chez qui ça fait cheap c'est que nous
avons aperçu de l'administratif
pléthoriques dans nos hôpitaux lieu
d'avoir le personnel soignant en
allemagne soit personnel soignant
beaucoup plus importante et des lettres
personnelles misrati et bien ça c'est
voilà un autre un autre point à un autre
débat qu'on aura merci beaucoup de nous
avoir suivis je donne la réponse à la
question alors question qui était êtes
vous favorable à l'annulation de la
dette des états due à la crise du coc
vide et vous répondez oui à 68 % à 58
pour cent cinquante-huit pour cent
cinquante métiers plus au début de
l'émission
il faut rembourser et surtout en
profiter pour réduire les dépenses dix
sept internautes qui se fait appeler
anonyme
en tous les cas on le reconnaît ce qu'il
est souvent là donc merci beaucoup en
tous les cas de nous avoir suivi et on
se retrouve demain même heure même
endroit avec guillaume roquette a très
vite sur figure au live
[Musique]